Kevin Spacey's departure from house of
cards was big news and rightly so
however after being fired from the show
the creative team behind it were forced
to change its ending in order to deal
with the absence throughout this video
I'll be discussing the original ending
that the producers had planned for
President Frank Underwood there are
potentially huge spoilers for the actual
ending of the show so if you haven't
watched that and I suggest you turn off
now but everyone else
I'm definition and let's get into the
original house of cards ending at the
end of season 5 Claire underwood Frank's
wife appeared to cut all ties with her
husband after Frank was killed under
suspicious circumstances
Claire became and stated as the
president and the main character of the
show Frank's absence didn't mean that he
was forgotten however and his ghost
loomed heavily over season six with the
main mystery being that of who killed
him eventually we learned that his close
aide Doug was responsible for Frank's
downfall after he gave the president an
overdose on medication but the original
ending was slightly different
well Joe recently reported that the
final season of the show was supposed to
center around Frank and Claire's bare
Debo's bowel something this scandalous
in politics would add a lot of weight to
the drama and give fans decide to choose
between Frank would go to the Shepherds
for help while de Clare would go her own
way as the infamous family held no sway
over the right has confirmed that Frank
would have died either way with the
original plans being the Claire would
snuff Frank out with the pillow and make
it appear to be a death of natural
causes the poisoning idea - originally
popped up and this is the only aspect
that remains from the show's original
planned ending at the end of season six
Claire was still destined to become the
president and the show would come to the
same conclusion just the journey would
be different
so what do you think of house of cards
original ending you prefer the one we
got and are you glad that Kevin Spacey
was an axe from the show comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please check out my breakdown
of the recent zombie horror flick
Overlord this is a channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
for taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you